اسرع والمسامير منذ نحو عام يساهم في عوده
ظهور مقاتلين الاجانب مما يصير مخاوف
امريكا مع وجود مقاتلين اجانب في اوكرانيا
قبل ايام نشر او نشر عبر موقع تويتر مقطعه
فيديو ازهار رستم ازيف او عبد الحكيم
الشيشاني اثناء اشتراكه في القتال على
الجبهه الاوكرانيه ضد القواتي الروسيه عبد
الحكيم الشيشاني كان قائدا تحت الفرق في
سوريا للمزيده ضم وليلى في الاستوديو وسيم
نصر اهلا بك وسيم نتحدث الان عن عبد
الحكيم الشيشاني وموجود حاليا بحسب هذه
الفيديوهات في اوكرانيا على جبهه محمود
يطرح كيف وصل الى هذه النقطه هولا نعرف
كيف وصل تحديدا الى اوكرانيا لكن انا نعم
انه تم ايقافه في تركيا خلال الاشهر
الفائته بسبب عمليه همم ضغط على اشخاص
لسحب المال منهم همم تم التبريته من
الموضوع واخلاق سبيله لا نعرف ان خرج
مباشره من تركيا الى اوكرانيا
من مره ببلد اخر علما ان عائدته تقطن في
همم في بولندا لكن من المعلوم اليوم انه
موجود هناك ولدينا صور لوصوله الى مدينه
ريفوي وثم ويمكن ان نراها هي فيديو وصوله
الى مدينه كريفوي ثم وصوله الى الجبهات في
محمود وهذه صور له في سوريا هذه خلال
معركه ادلب بعد اخذ مدينه ادلب من الجيش
السوري وهنا نراه عند وصوله الى اوكرانيا
منذ اشهر منقلد مع رئيس الحكومه في المنفى
همم
الشيشاني احمد زكي هيف اه واحمد زكي كيف
كان دعا المقاتلين شيشان للقدوم الى
اوكرانيا منذ عام 2014 وهنا نرى هذه الصور
من خلال شهر
الحالي لوصولي الى مدينه
القتال في محمود كان يمكن ان ربع الفيديو
لقتال في محمود حيث نرى انقراطه في
المعارك هذه خلال لكريفوي واستقباله من
قبل لجنه رسميه للمعارضه الشيشانيه
الموجوده في اوكرانيا منذ منذ سنوات نراه
مسلحه اي يتهيا لي همم الذهاب الى الجبهه
لانه وجب ان نعلم انه قائد عسكري ليس قائد
سياسي او له خبره عسكريه كبيره ونراه هنا
يطلق صاروخ ثم سنراه خلال معارك الشوارع
بعد بعد ثواني وهي معارك تجري في محمود
يعني من شارع الى شارع ومن بيت الى بيت
ومن ساحه بيت الى ساحه بيت ونراها هنا سوف
نراه هنا وهو يقول نعم هو يقود
الجنود همم هنا في تلك المعارف مواجهه
الجيش الجيش الروسي اذا هو له باع طويل
انجازات تعبير كان من احد القيادات في
معركه الثانيه ضد الجيش الروسي وصل الى
سوريا عام 2015 اي بموازات وصول الجيش
الروسي الرسمي الى سوريا لمسان الاسد
وكانت كانت عملياته في ما يعرف به في في
شمال همم
اللاذقيه وفي عده معارك قاتل الى جانب
الفصائل السوريه ومنها الجهاديه امم حيث
قاتل في معركه ادلب بجانب همم جبهه النصره
مثلا لكنه اول مفارقه بقي على حياد ايه في
كل ما حصل من قتال داخل الجامعات الجهاديه
او داخل الجامعات الجماعات الثوار جمال
ادلب وهذا المفارق ان لم ينضم للقاعده ولم
ينضم الى الدوله الاسلاميه وحافظ على
استقلاليه همم نوعيه همم من خلال تواجده
في الجبال جبال اللاذقيه هو وغيره من
الشيشان اي جماعه اجناد القفاز اي جماعته
لا تنتمي الى جماعه جهاديه عالميه
كالقاعده او الدوله الاسلاميه
توقيت ظهورها اليوم يعني ااا نتحدث مره
تقول انها جاءت من من بخموت ويخوض اذا
المعارف ضد القوات الروسيه سؤال ما الذي
ما دلاله هذا التوقيت لماذا الان عاد الى
الجبهه ومتى دعايات ذلك على الصراع بشكل
عام هو الان لان التوقيت يوافق الجميع
انجازات التعبير لان هيئه تحرير الشام
المسيطر على ادلب تسعى الى اخراج جميع
المقاتلين الاجانب من همم من سوريا وذلك
بموافقه التركيه من اجل الوصول الى الى
حلول ربما همم سياسيه على المنطقه فالسجون
هيئه التحرير الشام مليئه بالمقاتلين
الاجانب كانوا فرنسيين او غيره حيث تعطيهم
الخيار السجن او الخروج او حتى القتل في
بعض الاحيان انت تكلمنا عن جدي القائد
مثلا او الدوله الاسلاميه وهمم عبد الحكيم
الشيشاني كمسلم الشيشاني هو قيادي اخر
الخيار اي اخرج من ادلب
اه ولا او مصيركم سيكون السجن وهكذا خرجه
هو وغيره ونعود لي السؤال الاول كيف خرج
من تركيا لا نعلم ان كان هنالك من سهل له
الخروج من من تركيا وتداعيات وصوله الى
اوكرانيا هو ياتي تحت مظله الحكومه
الشيشانيه في المنفى التي
سيتم همم
متابعه ما يقوم به بدقه كثيره لانه حصل
قبل ذلك وصول مقاتلين شيشان الى اوكرانيا
عام 2015 وتما ترضدهم من اوكرانيا بعد
ثلاثه اشهر بسبب عدم انضباطهم ونحن اليوم
في قضاء محارب كبيره ونعلم ان اوكرانيا
والاجهزه الاوكرانيه ساهمت ايضا في قتال
مثلا الدوله الاسلاميه او القاعده حيث تم
تسليم قياديين من الدوله الاسلاميه
بعد هروبهم من سوريا مثلا ولكن اليوم في
خدم هذه الحرب بالطبع سيكون الاجهزه
الاوكرانيه سيطره اقل ومتابعه اقل لكن قيا
عبد الحكيم الشيشاني اظن سيتم متابعهم عن
قرب بسبب خبراتهم العسكريه وباعهم الطويل
في التل في في في تلك الشبكات التي بعثت
عالميا اليوم
عناصر اجانب اخرى على هذا على هذه الجبل
ولكن خوف من اتساع دائره الصراع والتغيير
اجانب من الجهتين حيث نعلم مثلا ان هناك
همم مقاتلين همم غير رؤوس وغير شيشان لان
الشيشان اصلا هم رؤوس تابعين لجمهوريه
روسيا اذا علمت اتكلم عن الشيشان بقاله
قديروف
هم يتبعون للرئاسه الروسيه اللي تبعون
الجمهوريه الروسيه وهم مقاتلين الروس في
نهايه الامر يقاتلون في اوكرانيا موسى لكن
لا يحسبون كم مقاتلين اجانب هذه المفارقه
لكن في صفوف مثلا همم مرتزقه كانتفاجنر
هنالك مقاتلين اجانب حتى من على الافارقه
اليوم يقاتلون وذلك موثق بالصور
المقاتلون الى جانب قوات راجنر في
اوكرانيا ومن ناحيه همم اوكرانيا هنالك
مقاتلين شيشان وذلك مقاتلين من جورجيا
هناك مقاتلين
من التتر مثلا اصولهم من جزيره القرم
يقاتلون في صفوف الجيش الاوكراني ان هنالك
هنالك وصول لمقاتلين من عده مناطق وبالطبع
من من من من من من الباديهيات ان الجهتان
اي روسيا واوكرانيا هدفها السيطره هؤلاء
لا تخرج الامور عن كان حصل في سوريا او في
غير همم